The joe rogan experience.
Have you had your man period lately?
No.
What's and I have this
theory that when we shit,
then it's all bloody in there that it's
possible that he does it at the same
time like it's based on the moon.
How often do you guys,
Shit when you get born your shit happens.
Happens every couple of months.
It goes for like a week feeling weak.
The hemorrhoid thing,
my hope.
Oh my God,
and then you wipe and you just like,
ah,
I'm still wiping a lot of shit.
Be like,
no.
It was just soaking red blood.
That's all.
There's no shit in it.
Die On your hand and I got to go
straight through the toilet papers.
Then you guys both need to go to a doctor
together and find out what aliens are
raping you in the middle of a shit study.
Do a fucking camera over your bed.
That's something really watched.
Aliens come in the room and take you
through the walls in the middle of the
night.
Return you later.
It's sometimes when you
stand up at your toilet seat.
Looks like Dexter,
like the blood spots that you know,
we didn't go in the water
if you have too low and man,
if you guys are both
shitting out that much blood.
Yeah,
I mean it pours.
It's the warmth.
It's like a warm faucet and turn it over.
Real thin beaker
sell you up for the shot girls.
Those that much water.
Not something to be proud of.
You guys are both really sick.
Jamie,
you okay with it?
Or you and I in the same boat?
I can tell you this though.
I did have a massive
diarrhea problem last week.
It was really worst diarrhea
problem I've had with a long time.
I do not know multiple days or
one diarrhea and multiple days.
I don't know if it was a stomach cold.
I don't know if it was something
that I ate that didn't agree with me,
but it was like one day I had a
headache and my head was like,
wow,
I feel sad.
I think it's like a food poisoning issue
cause I had an ha a headache and I was
like,
man,
I feel weak because it was the hairball.
No,
definitely not.
Definitely no more that.
Yeah,
it was um,
no it was,
it was post ham but I
hadn't eaten a ham for days,
but it definitely wasn't that.
It was something that I'd had I think
that day or before that day anyway,
diarrhea.
Oh my goodness.
I mean it was more than a
week after I'd eaten the Ham.
Now that I think about it.
Did you mix it with a regular
dump and have like a no dude,
it was just over the,
this is what happened in our whatever
was going on inside my stomach was
converting everything.
I ate into this liquid and
I didn't even make sense.
It was like define physics.
How solidified was it?
It was water.
If you dropped it on a UN inclined
table at a 40 degree in client,
would it go straight off the table?
Take a minute to go ride like a fucking
great wave straight through great brown
wave of destruction.
Dude,
it would rumble,
my stomach would rumble
and then I would go,
oh shit and I'd have really bathroom.
Then I'd get to the,
and I would hold it up whole
Marshall's like listen,
I wouldn't,
there's no way I was brave enough to fart.
There was no way.
There was no way cause I would get
into that tub or get it out of the bowl
rather.
And I would just hear whoosh just,
just,
just water tub my ass.
Complete water for like two days.
And then it like very untrustworthy shit.
I feel something that's worth day.
Yeah.
And I got hemorrhoids.
I had to go get preparation h oh no I
bought one squeezing it and pushing it,
trying to get it to come out so long,
which is really bad.
Pushed air bubbles into your asshole.
Well I think,
you know,
squeezing your ass like that,
trying to poop is very bad for you.
You're not supposed to do that.
And that's apparently one of the
things that causes hemorrhoids.
Long dumps.
So then,
but the preparation h
is a motherfucker dude.
Cause one day of that
cleared it right up really,
really quickly.
Just get the cooling their
core ranch one or the cool
for cool ranch sets.
Smell refreshing.
Find out people are
like putting it on food.
You can't eat that sir.
Preparation,
h measure preparation.
It was totally edible.
Whatever it does it,
it really works good and a good fixing
any sort of a hemorrhoid situation he got
down there,
they went away like within a day.
But man for fucking days,
four days of totally untrustworthy
shits the pasty shit where it's like you
could spread it on brick.
Oh I could spread it and stuff.
Yeah it was like leaves in there and
shit cause I still eat healthy but it was
like a lot of liquid.
It was some sort of a stomach bug,
whatever it was.
Um,
I don't have any idea where it came
from food or whether it came from just
catching a cold and you know that this
cold manifested itself as a stomach bug.
But whatever it was,
man,
it was crazy for a few
days and I felt real weak.
Like I go to pull my bow back and it was
like kind of difficult to pull the bow
back cause you're waiting from stumping?
Yeah,
no I was weak.
I was weak.
Like I would like pick
things out having it.
Yeah,
I could feel it.
Her friends.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely dehydrated but also
just I wasn't eating right.
Like I wasn't scared.
I wasn't getting hungry either.
I mean I was eating right and that I
was having like lettuce and s and salads
and stuff like that,
but I wasn't eating very much.
I wasn't eating like a like light meals
during the day because my stomach was so
untrustworthy that when
that happened at the area,
what is it?
What's happening?
I don't know man,
but whatever it was just
digesting it just too much.
I would eat like a steak.
I would have steak and some salad
and it would turn it a water.
Like how does steak and a salad become?
I mean my,
my body was liquefying it and
they would come out just whoa,
what is that?
Is it too much stomach acid
that just breaking down racism?
I don't know.
The the process.
I should probably know that shit on your
hand a little bit and sort of smelled
it right then and see
if there's some on it.
Enzymes on enzymes are
solving a digestion on it.
Pippy piles.
That's how it got me out of it.
I just had to do the time.
I just had to let my body process.
That sounds you just drink a
lot of water but in the Reps.
Yeah it was.
I was definitely thinking that I was
probably getting dehydrated from,
I was like so much water's
coming out of my ass.
Like I better make sure I
drink a lot to go with it.
All right.
Does your a hemorrhoid when it happens,
does it,
do you even feel the hammering?
Cause I can still feel it.
I feel like it's like,
oh I still have,
there's still some stuff
I've got to wipe off really?
Like oh that's just,
that's just my ass
a little while my bleeds.
I go whale.
Cause like a giant Turd.
That's just my ass now.
That's my shit.
Right.
It feels like what leads out.
It doesn't even feel anything.
It just,
that's that wheel that exploded inside,
isn't it in a way inside.
I don't even feel it.
Mine's,
mine's on the breast.
They're a diet that you can take,
stops that from happening.
Probably stuck behind hemorrhoids.
Finding foods.
Stop eating broken checks.
Lodge up inside your anal binding
foods and stay away from them.
Or do you a lot of them?
I forgot what it is.
Oh well you should probably know,
but it's one of those two.
So rice was in that group.
Binding foods are definitely away
from him or keep eat a lot of them.
I don't really go by the regimen,
but if you do do that it
would help prevent hemorroids.
Um,
yes,
that's my doctors don't want to.
Got It.
And um,
that's the 19th.
Do you need a lot of solid research?
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
Does that help at all?
I don't know.
I feel like it makes you shit more often.
Yeah.
But if you,
um,
if you doesn't it come out
like we need a lot of salads.
It comes out real easy.
Woo.
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
That's,
I guess a scraping,
pushing.
I used to pray it was so Jagat it'd be
so Jagat she claim that I would pray to
have a come out cause it hurts so bad.
Oh that's horrible.
That it was just so inflamed in there.
Cause I was just wasn't dumping
cause I knew it would be bad.
So I was like,
let me hold it for another few days.
Oh my God.
Days of dumping and get
compacts held off from days,
weeks at a time.
That's insane.
Shit.
Every week.
Dude.
That is so insane.
That's so insane.
Yeah.
I've never even heard that's toxic.
Like a,
so for sure you're containing
all that stuff in your body.
It's supposed to be evacuated.
Well it's in that spot.
Whatever that spot is.
Not Rubber it fucking,
I fill it up.
Dump,
but it,
we become too big for my ow.
Ow Jesus separated.
It's like your first time.
Your first time doing ain't no,
you fucked.
Mandingo that's pretty much what it was.
Use The asshole and it was
probably all dried up in there.
Right?
Right up.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Peace.
Jagged chunk.
Tearing you apart is your shit.
I would have to reach
in sometimes in terror.
Oh,
you had to do that dog
had to get a castrated.
Yeah.
Johnny,
I can't get his balls
removed because two things.
One,
he had an inflated prostate that was
pressing up against his colon and it was
making them constipated
and he was a in the,
in the hospital for a over a week.
I had to bring them in and they had
to try to figure out how to get him to
defecate because it's [inaudible] it was
back down and then they found out the
devastation was backed
up cause he was like,
he would like go to defecate,
but then he wouldn't,
it would get on this road and
it's like fucking Dover at Crouch,
but he couldn't poop.
And I knew there was something wrong.
So I brought him in and
they found out that it was,
his prostate was enlarged and you know,
he's an older male dog.
He's like seven now.
And so,
um,
I got them fixed.
So they take his testicles away,
which makes the prostate decreased to,
and then you got to have room to shit up.
Yeah,
I used to,
you know,
some people say that,
you should,
uh,
you should get a dog fixed and it's like,
it's healthier and happier for the dog.
But I had a veterinary,
didn't agree with that at all.
He said it's totally natural for
that animal to have its testicles.
He goes,
if the dog is,
if you,
you don't want them to breed
and as a female around,
get the female fixed.
And he goes,
and if you want to get the dog fixed,
you can,
but you don't have to get the dog fixed.
And he's like,
if you're not,
you're not making your dog a dad,
like forcing your dog to have to
breed and make unwanted puppies.
If you're not being irresponsible
with the dogs sexuality,
like you don't have to get the dog fix.
Can you just get it a sec to me?
Why if a cut the balls off,
let it still fuck doggie condoms.
Yeah,
because you don't want that
sense of a dog condoms.
You don't want that swelling.
It's the swelling that comes from the,
uh,
the testicles and the,
the enlargement of the prostate
that happens as they get older.
And that can be alleviated
by castrating the dog.
So the people get that.
I don't know.
I'm sure they do.
Humans were like,
I'm done.
Fucking,
I'm 72.
Yeah.
Just come on.
Come on.
Balls off.
I'm sure people do.
I'm sure there's people who've done that.
I'm sure there's,
people have just been tired of being a
prisoner to their cock and balls and just
said,
fuck you,
son of a bitch.
You run me for the last time.
Okra done.
Hold them on your hand for sure.
People had done that.
Cut Your own balls off.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.